that's gonna make a dent so
as a kid growing up in the 70s i love
science fiction movies my favorites
planet of the apes soylent green the
omega man
and of course fried green tomatoes
as a kid i imagine the future is
frightening and weird every day would be
like black friday at walmart
battling roves roving bands of marauders
who can forget mad max and its sequel
the road warrior riveting tales of
dystopian earth where
lawlessness reigns and survival becomes
a daily challenge
much like being married to cat
[Laughter]
then there's kurt russell as snake
pliskin and escape from new york in
later los
angeles funny how those walls worked
robocop a very funny film deadpan and
its take on a society sinking in crime
and ambivalence
i love these movies because like joy
behar remaining employed
i assumed it couldn't happen
[Laughter]
unless it could be caused by one major
event like a meteor strike or a
nuclear war or hillary becoming
president
[Laughter]
i had no idea that society through its
own inaction in cowardice could just let
it happen
day by day slowly until low and behold
the dystopia shows up at your front door
like a naked amway salesman
but that's what's happening the stats
say so but they're ignored the local
news says so but they're ignored too
america has become the frog sitting in
that pot of slow boiling water
having no idea that in time he'll be
some french guy's appetizer
which means it's time for
[Music]
yeah things don't look good
[Laughter]
oh yeah you ever hear a burgerville
it's a famous chain of burger joints
surprised
[Laughter]
in portland it had to close one of its
most popular places due to rising crime
homelessness and human waste it's true
apparently
their customers prefer their
cheeseburgers without a side of poop
amazing your business closes because
you're literally tired of all the
meanwhile denver spends way more money
on the homeless per person than on
students or
veterans new york too 800 million bucks
was spent on dealing with the homeless
problem
but have you been to new york lately
have you been to any major city
it's like burning man minus the good
drugs
some city streets look like the inside
of charlie sheen's mouth
[Laughter]
in san francisco a woman leans outside a
car window brandishing an ak-47
i guess pelosi is handling her own
security now
[Laughter]
in minnesota a man beheaded a woman on a
city street while they were sitting in
traffic
must have been a long light this week a
woman
shot another woman dead on a busy new
york city street before casually
returning to her white double parked suv
how did she not get a parking ticket
i'll tell you why
the driver had the hazard lights on
talk about priorities yeah there's
nothing worse than getting a parking
ticket piled on top of the life sentence
for cold-blooded murder
yeah go ahead and shoot him i'll just
turn on the hazard lights meanwhile a
woman kills her husband in indiana
chops him up and gets the kids to help
dispose of the body
and i used to complain when i was asked
to take out the trash
but i guess that's a good way to get
kids to do the chores and at least you
turn tragedy into some quality time with
the kids
in other news an elderly man gets
brutally beaten and no i'm not talking
about joe biden's latest approval
ratings
another in a wheelchair gets tossed and
ransacked by ghouls a would-be pervert
chokes a woman out and drags her off the
subway who knew andrew cuomo takes the
subway to work
straight gunfire strikes people sitting
on a bus in queens
men casually walk over and slug elderly
women on the street
other men rip jewelry off women's necks
in broad daylight that's 10 minutes of
research
on my part of the past week just 10
minutes
the same time it takes biden to answer
the question oatmeal or cream of wheat
[Laughter]
meanwhile what do you hear from the
media let's turn to the classic
if you watch a certain state tv and you
listen to conservative media you would
think that
you know entire cities are just you know
enrolled in
fights and fires and whatever we went
out had a great dinner
in new york city tonight people actually
walked up to us and said thank you for
i watch you every night i can't believe
they thought they did do a double take
at us actually
hanging out not seeing us on the tv
screen that clip has been played more
times than bingo at the villages
and it should and our politicians the
loudest voices say defund the police
but then they deny it and then later
they admit yeah that's exactly what we
want
i won't let them get that off you can't
get that off i'm going to make sure i
have security because i know
i have had attempts on my life and i
have too much work to do there are too
many people
that need help right now for me to allow
that so if
i end up spending 200 000 if i spend 10
10 10 more dollars on it you know what i
get to be here to do the work
so suck it up and defunding the police
has to happen
we need to defund the police and put
that money into social safety nets
her i know her slogan for the
re-election campaign
suck it up really you
expect me to believe people voted for
her in major cities all over life is
changing for the worse
and it's incremental but it's inexorable
and why is that why are we fine with
this
i think about this a lot when i'm not
fantasizing about stuart varney
i think i figured it out though it's a
perfect storm of distraction and
exploitation
we are distracted we have everything we
need an abundance of food
a never-ending faucet of trivia news cat
videos
everything instagram and tick tock keep
the young ones enthralled
twitter keeps the maniacs frothing over
microaggressions
porn keeps the boys glued to the screens
because there is no stop gap
and the cancel culture mob decides
whether we live or die we are the
luckiest generation of spoiled brats in
the history of the world
but because of that we stopped minding
the store and in walked the worst of the
worst
the radicals who said to themselves
while these suckers are nose-deep in
their phones we can do this
now they're in every power center
they're the politicians the da's the
professors the judges the social media
honchos
even kindergarten teachers so yeah i
finally got to live in the movies that i
loved
but sadly it's going to end like the
planet of the apes happy friday everyone
she's so sweet you can get a cavity in
your eyeball
just by looking at her outnumber co-host
emily compagno
she knows financing like i know belly
dancing and believe me that's a lot my
aunt
he's the tallest devito in recorded
history
writer and comedian joe ravito
she's like a plastic fork sharp can't
snap
and is sometimes spotted laying on the
street
fox news
that was the most upbeat monologue i've
ever written emily
happy friday happy hour has begun so i
have a question i've always been
thinking about this
if it goes really bad and the world
splits between
hordes of fiends and marauders and
good people trying to survive which side
would you be on
well the good ones for sure but you know
what why not just join the bad guys
and then you'll be safe emily because
more days living in hell
is not worth one day of living freely
and happily
i'd rather um and i feel like we're
seeing that play out in the city of
portland so you you mentioned the the
burger burger yes the um yeah charlie
foxtrot happening there
and their small business owners are now
paying
for armed security and for bulletproof
vests right now this is on top of all
their
lost revenue during covid it's on top of
their costs with covid compliance from
the government right and protection and
all that stuff
and then astronomical west coast taxes
and now their livelihoods have been
burned down in a hundred day plus riot
they're prevented from even operating
their small businesses because of feces
smeared on the walls
literally the other day my friend who
owns a bar there i have this on video
got into a fight with a bum that was
wielding a machete they call him ginger
kevin he's there all the time does he
have red hair
yes this is the reality that's facing
these small business owners now you know
why he's mad they call him ginger
because he has red hair
yeah we're still not working with social
workers in that city
so here's the point if the government is
breaching its duty
it's not protecting its citizens anymore
it's not prosecuting crimes it's not
deterring crimes there's no penalty for
any of these violent crimes
they're not protecting the citizens and
they're not preventing others from
from infringing upon your right to live
freely to operate a business why should
we pay taxes then
exactly why should we pay the salaries
of these guys who are abdicating their
duties who are incompetent
because clearly they're still going to
get elected over and over by that left
so i think we should just all stop
paying taxes that's my idea i'll see you
in jail
that's a true revolutionary
you know joe feces it doesn't sound
it's not as good as it sounds it's not
sounds cute like little mice
it's not and you see that here in new
york just the the the walk i have from
penn station to get to the subway it's
you think they'll walk through the penn
station
yes it's running this whole
and uh you know the walking dead is bad
the pooping living is no
pleasure either yes it's just it's so
horrifying what's happened
and and none of it is surprising when
you look back that
you know that we've gotten to this mode
where it's punishing people who are
productive
and rewarding people who refuse to
contribute and and when it gets to the
homeless issues we need to separate out
there are people who
are mentally ill right drug addicts you
need to help those people but the others
are are just sponging they're under 30
they're hanging i know them
i see them every day they're on my block
they're not interested
i've actually offered food and they they
get fussy yeah
yeah they have requirements is that free
range
yeah i'm free range my food has to be
free range
yeah so it's it's very depressing i mean
when you look at that poor
burger place and yeah how could they
margaret say well this burger's flame
broiled in a burning federal building
next door
they got to rebrand and just say come
here take a dump in the parking lot
although there has been a difference
that's why you're not in marketing
people are no longer asking though they
can use your restroom though they just
assume they can use
the dining area or the parking lot
exactly heather you uh you have uh
you're an optimist did i make you really
sad in the green room you were actually
crying while i was
editing my monologue it's tough to be an
optimist given the monologue but i think
um the empathetic argument should not be
increase the welfare state and
you bring up a good point joe that some
of the homeless do need help but in
general
if you look at the july jobs report this
morning it was great 954
000 jobs added the unemployment rate
down to
point four percent nine million job
openings which tells me
the empathetic argument is actually
giving the homeless a job
in getting them education and skills
training it's not
just to continuously give the money as
you pointed out denver pays on average
uh more they spend on homeless and they
do k through 12 education
and on average per homeless person
they're making
about the same as a median the median
person's income
that lasts in denver that's not so why
would you work
that why would you i'm moving to denver
right
we need you i love their omelets
[Laughter]
cat you know what i i see america as
like like a semi truck that went down a
blind alley so you can't turn around
you could only go in reverse
i know nothing about driving a semi
truck
[Laughter]
or driving so what's the solution
cat well look i think that the problem
is that it's a bit far gone at this
point i mean the city was
already literally on fire and the mayor
took the side of the people setting it
on fire
and then he's shocked you know
everyone's shocked that it keeps getting
worse
um i think that obviously you need to
first of all acknowledge reality that
would be step one
that would be step one is acknowledging
reality and saying this isn't working
this isn't working this isn't a problem
that social workers can solve
and i say that as the daughter of a
social worker
uh sorry she will she's dead now
like this is you you need law
enforcement yeah
or people aren't going to follow the
laws that's that's not hard well you
pointed out corey bush in the opening
monologue and she said she wants to hire
her own private security because she's a
victim of a crime
i heard trey gowdy say well who do you
think investigates
if you're a victim of a crime a
psychologist a social worker yeah
yeah also are you gonna call who doesn't
get death threats
yeah say that again and i'll kill you
exactly
last uh joe just last week he's got to
move on was i wrong to show the last
scene of the original plan of the aid
i'm i'm pissed off because that finally
showed up in my netflix queue after 50
years
got to know the ending of the planet of
the apes by now i'm excited it's like i
don't need to say spoiler alert yeah
even the apes are trying to leave the
planet now
they're hitting up jeff bezos to ride
shotgun
killer joke hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else